hey i'm justin this is peter we're here
with a gamespot breakdown vr has been a
really big part of GDC this year and
that's kind of following in line with
some of the oculus stuff that we've seen
so far and Peter you got to to see some
of the new oculus prototypes I we've
seen this at CES we've seen long
iterations of this over and over again
what's different about it now I've been
following the oculus since day one about
two years ago it was the first prototype
I used and that original model ended up
being the first development kit so what
they have now is dk2 development kit
number two and especially what they've
done is they've taken the CES model
Crystal Cove which implemented low
persistence Oh LED screen and front
displays in an added motion tracking
right so you have the low infrared
lights and a camera that tracks your
position it allows you to move around a
little bit more realistically in the
game and that's the one that we've seen
we saw at CES we've seen this one in
action but developers haven't had this
one yet not yet and before they even get
their hands on that tech they're also
going to be getting other tech in the
new development kit one of the things
they've added which I'm really excited
about is a USB port on the top now what
you can do is rather than powering the
oculus through a box a breakout box with
an adapter you can powered over 5 volts
through USB but if you want to add
accessories that's what's really
exciting because you can reconnect the
power cord to the oculus and use that
USB port to attach all manner of
accessories they're talking about you
know a little motion tracking camera
such as the leap motion you know
controllers perhaps a gun something like
that and if they give us any indication
of how much this is gonna cost is this
gonna add significantly to the price I
don't do that it comes with the camera
and you know it's like a brand new
design it's a it's much better than the
original one and they're gonna be
selling it for 350 our pre orders
started this morning at 8am oh wow so
minutes ago actually and they're going
to be distributed on a first-come
first-served basis it seems to be that
they're trying to get this out before e3
although we don't have an official date
for the first DK tues shipping I guess
what is the state of virtual reality how
does how does oculus feel about these
other competitors in this space I think
they're very excited because one of the
things that they've learned is that they
were not able to anticipate the sort of
experiences people are going to be
created so the community has sort of
taught the people at oculus like you
know
device can be used for more than gaming
or gaming in different ways than we're
used to so from their perspective you
know of course they're staying positive
about the competition they're not going
to put anyone down but they're looking
forward to innovations that may inspire
further innovations within oculus
they'll then make it to their future
prototype that said what they have right
now for the development kit to its
feature complete so when we see the
consumer model it'll have all these same
features with some slight tuning through
software but you know I got to say like
oculus has done a lot of work and it's
paid off and they've got a great product
so it's gonna be very tough for anyone
to compete with them in terms of price
point and features did they have
anything new to show off this time yeah
epic the guys behind unreal and games
like Gears of War they had a game called
couch nights where you say you and me
are sitting on a couch we each have a
controller in a VR headset and were
placed in a virtual living room with two
characters that we're controlling that
can jump on the table you know jump all
around the living room and we fight each
other it's a very simple experience I
mimics what you might see an AR game you
know where it would sort of falsely
project characters on a table but yeah I
mean it's really funny it's just it's
something that you wouldn't necessarily
care to play if it was just on your TV
but having dr having that immersion and
being able to sort of like tilt around
and look around your environment is is
very interesting and it's really
exciting time and i'm really looking
forward to trying out some more of this
VR tech myself you know stay tuned to
gamespot and we'll keep you covered on
all of the VR future that is right now